Rob just showed us how we can
make things accessible to
anyone who can't use a mouse or
pointing device.
Whether that's because it's any
type of physical impairment or
a technology issue or
simply personal preference.
You would have seen that,
while it definitely requires
some care and thought.
It's not a huge amount more work
if you plan it from the beginning.
And once that work is done,
you're already a long way down
the path to a fully accessible site.
Already, you've made your
site usable by more people
than if you hadn't addressed
keyboard usability.
And giving your site a more
polished completed feel.
In this lesson,
we're going to build on that work and
get you thinking about other
accessibility factors.
Like how do we build our websites
to support users like Victor
who can't see the screen at all?
We'll start with some background
on assistive technology.
The general term for
things like screen readers.
These are tools that are designed
to help users whose impairments can
prevent them from accessing
information technology at all.
Next up, we'll take a look at
the general user experience concepts.
We'll build on this to take a deeper
dive into the experience of users of
assistive technology.
Then finally we'll move in to how we can
use HTML effectively to create a good
experience for these uses.
And we'll see that actually
does overlap quite a lot with
the way we address focus.
First, let's talk a bit
about assistive technology.